countries around the world are working  to reopen their economies here slowly  but travel  is still restricted in many areas  tourist hot spots turned into ghost  towns  quickly and now they are trying to  attract tourists back  to those spots the ancient acropolis in  greece is now showcasing some modern  additions  with signs now promoting social  distancing it's interesting  meanwhile in italy churches are  reopening including saint peter's  basilica  pope francis actually led the first  public mass there in two months  and in the uk royal landmarks remain  closed but buckingham palace and windsor  castle  are offering virtual tours until they  can safely reopen  for many countries though the travel  bans will stay in place  through june